voir la planète s'effondrer en direct à
la télé ce sont des images qui laissent
sans mots et qui peuvent générer des
sentiments de colère et des puissances
de quoi même rendre simon goulet tina
oui échos anxieux on me dit de
d'étudier d'avoir un emploi d'avoir une
maison c'est simple le récit du progrès
mais d'un autre côté on dit que l'avenir
est voué une certaine façon qu'on
compare pas les conditions de base simon
a vécu de l'éco anxiété pendant des mois
un sentiment d'anxiété profond devant
les bouleversements causés par les
changements climatiques et
l'appréhension de leurs conséquences il
s'est senti perdu entre qui je suis où
est ce que je m'en vais c'est comme un
but puis la situation anticipé
ce avec quoi le futur l'écho inquiéter
est de plus en plus répandue noémie
larouche une journaliste scientifique a
écrit un livre sur le sujet fait qu'un
trouble réel
reconnu comme tel par l'association
américaine de psychologie
troubles qui définit comme une part
chronique du désastre environnemental
certains spécialistes parlent d'une
forme de stress très traumatiques
isabelle béliveau a aussi vécu de les
confier t elle a décidé de fonder
l'organisme eco motion un collectif de
professionnels qui donne des ateliers
dans les cégeps et universités pour
aider les gens à mieux vivre avec les
conquêtes et on va autant parler aux
étudiants que le personnel fait que les
intervenants psychosociaux mais aussi
les enseignants donc comment mieux
communiquer les changements
environnementaux d'une manière qui est
qu'ils peuvent par exemple qui va pas
est finalement à
nourrir à l'action climatique
une façon pour elle de mieux maîtriser
la situation et d'apprendre à
apprivoiser son et qu'on crie t isabelle
est étonné par la détresse qu'elle
entend c'est quelque chose qu'on
attention au chien capable de me
projeter dans le futur mes rêves mais
projet nous mon choix de carrière je
veux savoir des enfants au poste c'est
tous des questions a fait existentielle
que ces sentiments sont exacerbés par
l'impression que les gouvernements n'en
font pas assez pour protéger la planète
pour noémie larouche il est important de
bien accueillir les émotions qui
s'exprime c'est de reconnaître la
légitimité de ce qu'il éprouve ce
qu'elle éprouve fait normal d'être en
colère de vie de l'anxiété d'être de
sentir impuissant face à la destruction
sont environ c'est tout à fait normal
une étude publiée en 2021 mené auprès de
dix mille jeunes dans 10 pays révélé que
60 % d'entre eux se disent très inquiets
voire extrêmement inquiet par les
changements climatiques ici elisa série
radio canada montréal